يجب أن تكون التهاني هي الكلمة الأولى
عندما تستيقظ في الصباح ، ما المدة التي
تستغرقها لتدرك أنك بطل العالم في الفورمولا واحد
يوم الاثنين ، لقد كان الأمر صعبًا جدًا ، لقد كان من
الصعب جدًا الاستيقاظ قليلاً من الصداع
أيضًا  ولكن بعد ذلك أدركت أن لدي قدرًا
كبيرًا من التصوير لأقوم به أيضًا ،
مما أصابني بصداع
أكبر ، هل تتصالح مع الأمر ،
نعم أعرف بالطبع ولكن أه أعتقد
بشكل خاص بمجرد تسجيل الخروج قليلاً
من  الموسم ولديك القليل من
الوقت للاسترخاء ، سيكون أفضل
مقارنة بما كنت تتوقعه ، فأنت
تعلم كل تلك السنوات
التي حلمت فيها بأن تكون
بطلًا عالميًا للفورمولا واحد لا يمكنك أبدًا
كتابة نهاية موسم مثل هذا ،
نعم  لقد كان الأمر أكثر حدة مما
كنت أتخيله على وجه اليقين ، فأنت
تعلم بالضغط عليه طوال العام
ولكن أيضًا بالطريقة التي تعرف بها السباق الأخير ،
أعتقد إذا كنت
ستخبرني في الليلة السابقة
ربما كنت سأفعل  لقد نمت لذا نعم
حقا  هل نمت في
الليلة التي سبقت نومي ولكن ليس
بشكل طبيعي وهذا مؤكد مدى
ثقتك في الصباح
، من الصعب دائمًا معرفة ذلك لأن
السباقات القليلة الماضية كانت
سريعة جدًا وبالطبع كنت في
المركز الأول  لكنني كنت أعلم أنه سيكون
سباقًا صعبًا للغاية ، وبعد
ذلك بالطبع ،
خسر السباق على الفور الصدارة ، لذلك
شعرت أن هذا رائع ، إنها
بداية رائعة ثم من هناك مرة واحدة لأنني
كنت أضيع
الوقت وفعلنا ذلك للتو  ليس لدي السرعة
وكان الأمر صعبًا ، لكنني أيضًا قلت
لنفسي إنني سأبذل قصارى جهدي
فقط ،
سأذهب إلى أقصى حد ، وكفريق
أعتقد أننا جربنا كل
ما نعرفه  حتى مجموعة أخرى تحاول
سد الفجوة مرة أخرى ، ثم بالطبع
مع بطاقة الأمان ، دخلت النهاية
مرة أخرى بإطارات جديدة أو إطارات
جديدة ونعم لم نستسلم أبدًا وهذا
أيضًا ما جربته في السباق الذي ظللت آمله للتو
الاعتقاد بأن شيئًا ما
سيحدث